yeah what I'm a new video against an
international master here from Venezuela
you don't have that too often so on on
the Rue La Paz so what line player all
kinds of lines against the room that's
some okay the exchange yeah 93 93
there's some a bunch of possible answers
here I go Queen f6 to some somewhat them
underestimated move also on castles okay
just take it it's um it looks like black
has lost the tempo and in fact this is
true I am I really am a tempo one move
down on on some line but fortunately
this line that done I'm lacking a temple
to in comparison is relatively harmless
so on f5 was one idea but this is not
working at the moment this is the one
problem with this position positions as
that it is very very tedious to play
sometimes you need to be rather patient
there's not so much some threatening or
or dangerous happening but you can
easily overlook some some small detail
and then you're really into trouble it
can it can happen here for instance um
he's trying to to double on the D file
and it looks like he might manage this
how to set up the pieces here I really
I really would like to exchange one rook
one day of rooks yeah okay maybe this
way there should be seven now winds may
be a temple but ok it's got Knight to g5
this is a problem ok maybe I need to be
I need to be M a bit little bit cautious
it also have young need to be rather
modest as black you don't really have
have much you can do ok this defends c7
and so on and i have this way to 23 my
position a bit but it looks nice for
white but it's not so evident how how is
going to continue now one idea that i
have is 95 to see for which would be
very strong if I really would manage to
get get the night to see form he's got a
very bad night on b3 so this is his main
main problem
yeah he's taking a bit of a timeout it's
not easy this mb3 night Isis yeah it's
really tricky tricky position but I
don't think this really could control me
I think exchanging one pair of rooks
must be must be helpful the question now
is 95 form or some other with rookie
adium you create would would win a
temple here's some bishop oh wait wait
wait just just just just Bishop g5 of
course just Bishop g5 Bishop g5 f4 night
x f4 yeah I had this idea before Bishop
g5 and just I forgot about it so okay is
giving up the exchange now be sure to e6
yeah this is nice the bishop now it's on
a very good post night f4 or 95 95 looks
it looks good to see 42 d 3 so further
exchanges yeah
check yeah it's a it's an exchange and
he's got those those weaknesses how to
do this let's go here and then possibly
enter with the rook also of course he's
6 and b5 something that would help me so
it wants him
okay let's try to go all the way to
before possible I hope the aid also
would have been good but I can still do
that rope d3 he cannot go to see 30
really rock d3 and rock d 3 next move is
really strong the text the bishop and
the porn here you'll see that this
Bishop is always dominating the night
this is this is important you make some
of the technical task easier now just
grab the g2 porn and I still have all
those the sister serve those pawns
jumpy too it's not there not instantly
winning I can also use the C porn in
addition
can now the bishop will go to skoo to e4
and also got an edge porno so it's a
rather comfortable only 28 seconds give
give white some some sleight hopes came
so right 94
yeah 11 seconds it's not not too much
Jeff check check
yeah but no let the clock run down a I
didn't choose the most efficient way but
it's sometimes really weird i don't know
what people are doing why not just
resign and got to get on with the next
game or whatever you might play move
like two seconds or so what happens yeah
no idea i don't i don't really know what
did i do something to to provoke him or
whatever and step besides winning i mean
yeah i came i did this at some point it
looked really a really nice for why this
kind of position I don't know it looked
it look better for wide but maybe
there's not much happening it it
sometimes this deceptive and really
quickly and it was it was a problem at
5am this already is quite nice for like
I'm the computer gives plus 1.7 for
black this is cool yeah I mean okay to
bishops and he's got he's got bad nights
on be 3n d5000 is not a bad night it
looks nice on d5 but what it is doing
what what exactly is the role of this
piece yeah very quickly he got into into
the size of problems him I could have
won much quicker i'm sure but i think it
was sufficiently effective i mean that
he didn't they have a chance to to save
alright thanks for watching